Most of you probably know that Eric Trump
is not exactly the one we typically refer
to as the smart one.
But he even outdid himself in a completely
wacky interview on ABC on Sunday with Jonathan
Karl.
Now, Eric Trump was interviewed, I guess,
as a surrogate of the Trump administration
or a surrogate of the Trump campaign.
I think better said fine.
But as you watch this, I want you to understand
and consider that the importance of beating
Trump this election this November.
It's not just about preventing Trump from
being president for another four years so
that the country doesn't go completely off
a cliff.
Another reason why we must defeat Trump this
November is that if we don't in 2024, I guarantee
it, either Eric or Don, Junior or Ivanka are
going to have a leg up in the Republican primary
for president in 2024.
At some point, one of them runs.
And I believe that if Trump gets another four
years, you will see at least the possibility
of an attempt at one of his kids running.
And this interview should be a reminder as
to why we need to stop that at absolutely
all costs.
We know that the Republican electorate is
really ignorant.
They aren't going to stop the Trump kids.
So we need to prevent them from getting a
running start by Trump getting another four
years in November.
So let's get into the clips.
Eric Trump on this week again.
You know, he's supposedly just a businessman
at this point, but he's there as a surrogate
of the Trump campaign.
Doesn't really make sense.
But he's there and he is mad that the media
will accurately report when Trump does these
mass rallies.
It risks spreading the virus.
Take a look at this.
I mean, they took every precaution against
temperature checks, masks.
They were outside.
It was a beautiful event.
Sure.
Why is it that it's only Trump events that
are called that?
Why?
Why are these protests that we see all over
the place?
I see them in New York.
I see them in Portland.
In Seattle.
I see them everywhere.
He is going wild.
No one ever talks about them wearing masks
again.
A beautiful protest by African-Americans and
Hispanic Americans in front of the White House
to support our incredible men and women in
law enforcement becomes the subject of an
ABC show at 9:00 a.m. on a Sunday morning.
I mean it well.
Well, Erick Erickson, to be clear, I'm not
I'm.
I've lost a lot of faith in the media.
John, I really have.
Well, Eric, to be clear, I'm not criticizing
and I'm reporting the fact he's totally incoherent.
What is he even talking about?
These mass events do have the potential to
be super spreader events.
Period.
And the fact that the media is covering them
as such is because the media is doing a good
job.
Of course, he's not pleased with it.
Eric Trump then admits that Trump is having
rallies at the White House.
Now, this is problematic for two reasons.
Trump has been playing coy and saying these
are peaceful protests because if you call
it a protest, that's OK.
You can't call it a rally.
It's a problem.
But it's also a problem because you're not
supposed to use the White House for political
campaigning and by calling it a rally.
Eric Trump, again, nobody said maybe he says
I've never claimed Eric Trump is the smart
one, but he's admitting that these are rallies
at the White House pretty.
And you know this you report from there every
single day.
Everybody that goes within 500 yards of the
White House is tested every single day.
And it's a little bit of a different apparatus,
you know, in that machine.
But again, I just find it I find hypocrisy
so crazy.
I mean, you go out there and you see these
massive, massive riots and protests and these
liberal run cities and no one's wearing masks
and no one cares.
No one cares.
The media doesn't talk about them.
I mean, how many have we had New York and
how many have we had in Chicago and all these
things?
And the media never talks about that.
But again, when you have a peaceful Trump
rally at the White House in support of law
enforcement by African-Americans, CNN cuts
away.
You know, MSNBC cuts away for those events,
you know, truly the rantings of someone completely
disconnected from reality.
He really seems to think that he and his family
are just the biggest victims out there.
They're martyrs.
They've agreed to be the first family to fit
you, despite what would be best for them in
order to just make things better for everybody
and everybody attacks them.
Of course, the big differences include that
everyone is wearing masks at the various protests.
That's why they don't seem to have spread
the virus.
Eric Trump, who is clearly not an expert in
any of these matters, then goes on to talk
about Donald Trump.
Taking a vaccine now, it's false that as far
as we know, Trump didn't get a vaccine during
his treatment for Corona virus.
He got medications, but not vaccines.
And certainly Donald Trump has done nothing
in terms of creating a vaccine.
But Eric Trump, bizarrely says here Donald
Trump took a vaccine and the interviewer,
Jonathan Karl, can't believe what he's hearing.
Take a listen to this.
Hey, guys.
How did a hundred percent.
It was amazing.
It actually probably goes to speak to.
We have good some of these vaccines that are
being created are.
And what my father's done on the vaccine front,
no one could have done.
No one could have done.
I mean, literally, my dad was calling my father
xenophobic for shutting down America from
from travel to China.
I mean, the virus came from China.
My father literally started day one creating
this vaccine.
He worked to push this vaccine.
And now my father just took it.
And you see how well he got over it.
What can you do?
Inspiration.
I think as Americans, John, we should be very
proud of that.
Can you clarify that?
You said your father just took a vaccine.
Meaning, when he was in Walter Reed, the medicines
that he was taking and the therapeutic, he
felt horrible.
And on Saturday, again, I spoke to a man three
times on Saturday and he sounded tremendous.
And I think it goes to show the power of medicine
in this country and how far that, you know,
that we've come on Cauvin, in the last, you
know, six, seven months, vaccines cured.
My dad.
Which my dad created, despite Joe Biden being
xenophobic.
What's what?
My father took a vaccine.
Huh?
What doesn't make any sense is Eric.
Now, there's a there's one idea, which is
Eric Trump let slip that Trump has received
a vaccine, but they're not going public.
I just think Eric Trump's dumb.
I don't think he's letting anything slip here.
Eric Trump then was asked about the fact that
Donald Trump called Kamala Harris a monster.
And Eric Trump, of course, defends it.
This is funny.
Vice President Pence, when he debated Kamala
Harris, said it was a privilege to be on the
stage with her.
I recognized her history making pick is as
Biden's running mate.
And then the next day, your father said that
she was a monster.
What white?
How was Kamala Harris?
A monster white.
Why did he say that?
Well, you know, I think a lot of the answers
that she takes that are just mind boggling
to me.
I mean, she's come out and she's called to
abolish law enforcement.
She's, you know, compared to members of ICE,
the KKK in a congressional hearing.
She wants to take away hundred and eighty
million private health care plans in this
country.
Last week, she was coming out talking about
how she literally she wanted to limit the
amount of red meat that Americans could eat.
I mean, I would put Eric, but.
Eric.
Political differences.
I think you've mischaracterized her positions
in that litany.
But political differences are one thing.
A monster you're calling the Democratic vice
presidential nominee a monster.
Your father did.
How is that?
I mean, I don't I don't get it, John.
You know, you're also dealing with a person
who is willing to lie every single day.
You know, it's amazing.
One day they're calling for the littlest Kamala
Harris and frankly, Joe Biden.
But I love that when Eric Trump says you're
dealing with someone who's willing to lie
everyday.
Jonathan Karl says who?
It's a completely Kafka esque moment.
That's not I don't know that we've ever used
the term Kafka esque on this program before.
It is a completely surreal Kafka esque moment.
Eric, when Eric says you're dealing with someone
who's willing to lie every day.
Jonathan Karl is confused because there's
no bigger liar in politics right now than
Donald Trump.
I guess Eric was talking about Joe Biden or
Kamala Harris, but a completely wild moment.
Also, he's lying by saying Kamala wants to
abolish police.
That's hilarious.
She doesn't.
In fact, people are some people on the left
don't like Kamala because she doesn't want
to abolish police.
She doesn't want to take anybody's health
care.
And then Eric Trump ends this interview, which
didn't go well, claiming that it's a lie,
that we know who all of Donald Trump's creditors
are.
And you can tell he's particularly triggered
by this one because he starts speed talking
and making even less sense than he had been
making throughout the interview.
The media's become the activist arm for the
Democratic Party.
Eric Eric, I think is fair.
Eric where?
Eric Raskin asking legitimate questions.
One last one.
The New York Times report also said that the
president owes some 400 million dollars.
Don't the American people have a right to
know who he is indebted to, who the president,
the United States owes money to?
Can you clarify that for us?
Johnson Financial disclosures.
You know exactly where the money is owed to
that.
That's another Democratic talking point that
you just you know exactly how the money is
owed to my car.
I don't billions of dollars and on a portion
of his net worth.
My father has very, very, very low leverage.
In fact, The New York Times, if you want,
bring them into this.
They came out and said that the other day.
If you own if you own buildings, if you aren't
real estate, you carry some debt.
That's that's what developers do.
That's what business owners do.
They carry some debt.
Now, that's a proportion of his net worth.
It's incredibly low.
We have a phenomenal company, but there's
nothing new about that.
And by the way, it's the same debt that he
got elected on.
And it's awfully disclosure his financial
disclosure forms weren't in our government
that you have access to.
Eric, Eric, thank you for joining us.
I appreciate your time on this Sunday morning.
Thank you.
We have a phenomenal company, he says that
lost money so that we could get tax breaks.
But it's a great company.
It just happens to be in direct conflict with
what we learn about the profitability of the
company through the bombshell New York tax
report.
New York Times tax report, which said the
business actually was a disaster, many years
painful to listen to.
And again, he's there.
Eric Trump is as a surrogate for the campaign,
although he supposedly has no role in anything
government or campaign related.
He's merely an independent businessman.
Can you make any more sense out of it than
I can?
And do you agree with me that of the three
adult Trump children, Ivanka, Don, Junior
and Eric, Eric's by far the worst in these
interviews?
Let me know if you agree
or disagree